foreign
[Music]
today we're going to discuss the secrets
Easter eggs and some other references
you might have missed watching the newly
released light year if you haven't
watched the movie yet press pause watch
it and then come back because we're
going to discuss some spoilers if you
like the video be sure to leave us a
like And subscribe to the channel to not
miss out on any future content regarding
your favorite animation movies without
further Ado let's get started
in the Toy Story movies you can't
isolate Buzz Lightyear from a Space
Ranger costume even after taking a few
minutes beyond the bubble headgear in
light year buzza seemed to become the
most himself when he's decked in the
green Galactic Alliance costume the
Space Ranger outfit certainly appears in
a few successive variations all through
light year with the original version
from the early part and the enhanced
version in the final episodes being the
two key ones they both seem to have a
lot of details from Toy Story that
longtime enthusiasts will doubtlessly
acknowledge the light year suit is an
exact reconstruction of the toy under
the three vibrantly colored knobs on
Buzz's chess lab one of whom is again
and again used to stimulate stealth mode
and the wrist networker he's clearly
talking in and out of is much more than
a bumper sticker this time about or at
the very slightest the latest design
shown at the end of the movie is the
slightly older outfits have a foreign
beam of light and a big red tab rather
than a switch on its front which is
brought to light to be the Despicable
surrender button though by the end of
the movie buzz and his Squad have all
succeeded in getting their fancy new
Space Ranger retired something that
every kid in 1995 desired
Buzz Lightyear is an awesome Gadget as
the Toy Story films repeatedly tell us
he has karate chop action a beam on his
forearm and a flying launcher all of
these special capacities have been used
in light year with a few of them being
extremely crucial buff exhibits his
karate chop action across many places
all through the film which expresses a
much more powerful and flexible
Gathering of fighting skills his forearm
beam is not included in the old Space
Ranger costume prototype but in the
third conduct Buzz mixes It Up by
attaching a relatively small handheld
laser pointer to his forearm for
convenience the instrument comes in
useful all through a struggle with Zerg
and when the fresh Space Ranger outfits
are disclosed at the end of the scene
they all have forearm laser beams
assembled along Pixar retains Buzz's
flying wing suit hidden for a large
percentage of the movie Buzz only jumps
the flippers to assist keep the vessel
on track as the rest of the players
rejoin the surroundings in their ship
everything continues to work out however
the re-entry could be categorized as
plunging with Aesthetics
Alicia Hawthorne is a hugely important
secondary character in light year the
light year movie introduces her as a
Star Command Soldier and Buzz's workmate
her real surname must have been directly
influenced by spacex's head office in
Hawthorne California in the following
scene there is a massive fuel stability
display case trying to imply that the
crystalline sources of Power are
volatile and unpredictable and yet are
mainly accountable for bus's space
launch breakdown
Pixar is well known for parodying Star
Wars and its Buzz Lightyear narratives
Zerg is primarily a big ridiculous
magenta Darth Vader with a designation
of Emperor Palpatine and if you start to
think light year was the final stage of
Buzz's Star Wars quotes you'd be totally
incorrect the big one in light year is
much less evident than those in the Toy
Story movies but that should be
noticeable to fans of both installments
socks Buzz's cyborg cat buddy can
converse with multiple operating systems
via connector on the edge of his tail
when he commences hacking his head
starts spinning 360 degrees and it
begins in Earnest to mumble beep-op beep
bop repetitively it's hilarious if
simple choke and it appears to be a
direct link to R2D2's own cyber crime
behaviors in Star Wars while R2 may not
be the only famous sci-fi machine to
decrypt into computer networks hellsox
appears to be going about his job and
the noises he creates are virtually
identical to the robot in specific seems
like each and every Galactic hero
probably requires a robot partner with a
USB connection
according to the Toy Story chronology
light year was launched in 1995 while
the movie could have easily dismissed
that information later on it continues
to be a significant part of the overall
aesthetic much of the movie is
influenced by ancient sci-fi Brands
including Buck Rogers however there are
a few specifics that genuinely feel
peculiarly 90s for instance all through
Buzz's first Hypersonic missile flight
test his flight computer Ivan begins to
break down Buzz retrieves Ivan from the
vessel's framework displaying it to be
anything but a jagged plugin and keeps
blowing into it as though it were an NES
cartridge yes of course the automatic
pilot instantaneously begins working as
designed that is not the only 90s
information that shows up several of the
electronic monitoring systems in light
year have the bulky overlays of 1990s
desktop displays which makes perfect
sense from movies set in 1995. clearly
Lightyear gathers from all ages of
sci-fi but its primary design feels like
a contemporary animated feature film but
it's still fascinating to see how the
creators perpetrated the mid-1990s
aesthetic in a number of different ways
there are a lot of dialogues in light
gear that are elevated straightforwardly
from The Toy Story Blockbusters some of
them seem to be evident to anyone who
has seen the earlier movies for instance
at the beginning of light year while
buzz and Alicia are investigating the
alien Globe Buzz publishes a task log
trying to comment on the scenery
monitoring that the landscape appears to
be uncomfortable of course in the
initial Toy Story he says exactly the
same thing while strolling about on
Andy's bed there are so many of these
little reference points all through
light year Masterpiece is like I'm Buzz
Lightyear I'm always sure and not today
Zerg will actually stand out to everyone
who pays heed to them and they add a
soft finish to the movie by integrating
it with Toy Story it's interesting to
see how the toy Buzz takes inspiration
and personality characteristics from his
Fantastical self and the innumerable
buzzwords are a great way to Showcase
this
the Toy Story movies paint a more
attractive environment the universe is
visually appealing and seems to be
pleasant however later depicts somewhat
depressing illustrations rather than a
vivacious configuration and backstory it
seems to be Dusty and robotic comparable
to Pixar's Wally another indication is
indeed the dawn-like brightness
light years climax foretells a promising
future for Buzz his mate and the
galactic Alliance the Space Ranger
organization is reinstated with slashing
and Advanced Technologies and buzzer
Squad is officially recognized for
elevated deployments their first mission
is to support experiments in sector 4's
gamma quadrant if you've ever seen Toy
Story you might acknowledge that
destination when Buzz initially arrives
in Andy's room he affirms that he is
garrisoned in sector 4's gamma quadrant
the position is stated again in Toy
Story 2 where Buzz's computer game fight
with Zerg occurs given that perhaps the
evil Monarch is found to be completely
awake at the end of light year an
updated model of that combat could
actually occur in a spin-off in a
particular instance it's Pleasant to see
Pixar adhering to the ridiculous
mythology they've developed over the
years because the buzz toy has all of
his fantasy self's remembrances it
logically follows that he would have a
deep relationship with sector 4's gamma
quadrant
much of the plot of light year tends to
revolve around crystallic Fusion the
Sci-Fi procedure through which Star
Command and its Representatives
accomplish hyperspeed in their space
Vehicles when Buzz and the other
inhabitants of sc01 collapsed at the
start of the movie their old combustion
nucleus are torn down attempting to
force them to try out new things with
the available materials in the desperate
hope of building a different one it's a
decades-long method that entails Buzz
falling short of multiple studies with
crystallites that are just fractionally
off eventually his machine partner socks
emerges with the perfect workaround
leading to the establishment of a
comprehensive crystallic Fusion Center
of course crystallic Fusion was always a
core component of Toy Story mythology in
the original movie all through buzz and
Woody's first discussion Buzz presents a
variety of questions to his prospective
best mate choosing to believe himself to
have arrived on an alien world in the
naive hope of restoring his vessel he
Ponders to Woody about readily
accessible forms of energy do you still
use carbon fuels or if you unearth
crystallic Fusion he asks of Woody who
retorts completely baffled we've got
Double A's in the Majestic framework of
factors this is a small thing entombed
in a passing remark so it's soothing to
see light year remain committed to the
core principle in its own narrative
light year wouldn't have been thorough
without appropriate combat between buzz
and Zurich and the movie actually
delivers that the two are actively
involved in a protracted fight that
stretches zerg's Battleship and even
stretches to the open area just
underneath it with Buzz ultimately
springing up triumphant well not a
complete duplicate the light you're
fighting bears resemblance to the Zerg
confrontations in the Toy Story movies
for instance the episode in which buzz
leaps and front flips over all of Zerg
before having turned to rapidly shoot a
laser back is directly lifted from the
Buzz Lightyear computer game that Rex
tries to play at the beginning of Toy
Story 2. thank goodness the genuine Buzz
is more blessed than Rex of course the
final round against Rivals quarrel and
light year which happens in space offers
An Elegant interaction between both of
them we all knew this was coming but it
was still fascinating to hear Zerg
demands Buzz to prepare to die and Buzz
replies not today Zerg
that's it for today have you noticed
some of these secrets already did we
leave out another secret or Easter egg
let us know in the comments down below
be sure to leave us a like if you
enjoyed the video and subscribe for more
content on the biggest upcoming
Blockbusters until next time
[Music]